I want to talk about it I want you to
talk about his brain and what in what we
know actually physically what what do we
know from Einstein so you need to tell
the story about what actually happened
for those in the audience who well you
know cut me off because it's a long
story but it begins that brain the story
the brain begins when he passes away on
April 18 1955 he knew he was going to
die he'd actually been living on
borrowed time he had an aortic aneurysm
abdominal aortic aneurysm and he didn't
have much he could do for it in those
days he'd actually had an operation
several years earlier they they would
wrap cellophane around it with the idea
that you'd scar down to keep it from
rupturing but it didn't hold and it came
back and he knew it and so April 18 1955
he passes away others a few words of
indecipherable journey German we don't
know what he said and the the body is
taken down for the autopsy the routine
post-mortem determined the cause of
death and had he left instructions no
nothing nothing there is nothing in the
will about the disposal of his body
somehow it was known that he wanted to
be cremated that that was known April
19th which that thing he just showed was
the next day in New York Times his
family basically his son Hans Albert and
his executor Otto Nathan read that the
brain has been kept and they're going
what nothing mentioned in the will but
that was like not on the script and they
go to the pathologist Thomas Harvey a
guy in his 40s who's the only chief
pathologist at this little medical
little Hospital Princeton hospital and
Harvey pitches the the pitch of his life
and he says we're never going to get
another chance like this let it let me
study the brain and Hans Albert goes for
it and so does Otto and anything so what
do we know what do we know as a result
of preserving I mean I can show you some
pictures let's do that okay let me tell
you what we don't know we'll start okay
okay it's not a bigger brain it's not a
bigger brain okay that's not bigger it's
not very 1230 grams not a big brain so
if you're into the bigger is better
doesn't work for central nervous system
but the architecture is
different and rather than me say well
this squiggle goes here and that's good
let me shake okay all right so let me
just okay let me just orient your real
quick cut me off if this goes too long
okay frontal lobe that's the back of
your brain this is his right this is his
right hemisphere that right there is a
split the hemispheric split
interhemispheric split okay just a
highlight the game highlights on this
okay here's your front frontal lobes 1 2
3 4 4 frontal gyrate great great
majority we don't have all of us have
three he had four that is a serious
anomaly how do we know that because
there are standard atlases of brain
anatomy Ono and Connolly and again I am
stealing from my colleague Dean Fogg
who's the real anatomist in this and she
poured over this brain but in any event
that is not standard issue that frontal
lobe okay so one more makes a big
difference okay got it yeah I mean
that's the you know if I say anything
more than that you're gonna say well
your phrenologist and I'm not all I can
tell you is the brain is different and
the guy was a genius that's all I can
tell you that's not going to get you an
a on the final okay oh I know I'd love
to say okay all right there's your
cortical knob the violin part see that
thing cortical knob that's on the right
hemisphere so that's presumably what's
in a knob we well I'll call it an Omega
sine call it a kink they just the
literature calls it a knob you see it's
that little I'll say better but that
little u-turn there yeah that's not
standard issue and there's stuff we
don't even know this is this is a
diagonal sulcus
here there's no name I talked to Dean
Fogg emailed her this morning there's no
name for that thing it's not described
in regular anatomies anatomy textbooks
so he's got a lot of variant Anatomy
okay this is if you cut the brain in
half okay all right so that's the
frontal lobe that's your occipital lobe
that's your corpus callosum
that's the fiber pathway that connects
up your right hemisphere with your left
hemisphere we didn't do it we recovered
this photograph these photographs have
been lost for half a century we recover
these photographs and now we start to
analyze them and dr. men wait wait men
out in East China Normal
seize the photo goes wow look at that
corpus callosum sets up a computer
program he's got a larger than normal
corpus callosum large not age long for
an age match guys but for even young
people
he's got greater internal wiring
anatomically with his corpus callosum
which opens up a whole other can of
worms where you're not really talking
about the stuff on your surface on your
cortex you're talking about the internal
wiring and he obviously this is a sign
of greater white matter internal wiring
or if you want to use the sexy new terms
connectome
he has a different connect dome so his
brain really was different than
everybody else's no doubt about it